the league has been united but audiences
don't seem to care so much so I don't
normally talk very much about box office
numbers at least not on the YouTube
channel if you listen to my my podcast
feed you know that that comes up
regularly on one of the shows there but
it's not something I generally talk
about here because it's not something
that is of excessive interest to me
beyond just oh okay so that that's what
that number is but I've had now a number
of people kind of asked for my
assessment on what happened with Justice
League's opening weekend and if you
don't follow box off num in box office
numbers Justice League opened with 96
million for its opening weekend now a
couple of points of comparison for that
the first the other major comic book
related superhero movie to come out this
month Thor Ragnarok opened at over 120
million so in terms of things of in a
similar vein and yes I understand major
differences between DC Marvel but come
on they're both superhero movies go with
me in terms of something opening in a
similar vein and close to it two weeks
apart underperformed from that and
Justice League should theoretically be a
bigger name that's the first thing
second thing it is the lowest opening
weekend for any movie in the DC EU it is
lower than Man of Steel it's lower than
Batman V Superman is lower than Suicide
Squad it's lower than Wonder Woman and
additionally it underperformed to
expectations it was projected to open at
around a hundred and ten million so even
though that was still would have put it
behind Thor it would have put it say
ahead of Wonder Woman and you know it
may have not been what they wanted
really but that would have been a decent
so when there were projections and it
didn't even hit those and came in as the
lowest box-office take for an opening
weekend in the DC EU movies at all
that's that's kind of notable so there's
two questions that one has to ask about
that the first is what happened the
second one is what's next
and some people who've asked me for my
opinion this have also asked you know
what are your thoughts on the critical
reaction I really don't have too much of
a thought on that I suppose the thing is
like I enjoyed Justice League to my own
shock but I think part of the thing is
there you know people people like to
wield the sword both ways of the you
know critic should be objective and I'm
sure there are some people who are
saying that you know the oh they're
biased in favor of Marvel and all this
I'm sure some folks are saying that
what-have-you but if you're trying to be
objective about it there is a lot wrong
with this and I think a big part of why
I did enjoy Justice League is AI was
grading it on a curve relative to the
other DC EU movie the only one of which
I enjoy prior to this was Wonder Woman
and B I went in with a really low
expectations if I'd had a clean slate
and just watched Justice League cold I
probably would not be very impressed
with it so it's a case-by-case basis
with critics but if I were to just guess
if they were trying to not let things
influence him them too much and just
looking at as a film it's not great it's
decent but it's not great again I had
fun with it but there's a lot off about
it but I don't want I don't want to
focus on the critical reaction because
previous films in the DC EU had lousy
critical receptions Batman V Superman
had a lousy critical reception Suicide
Squad had a lousy critical reception
they still made good money so I I want
to I would rather focus on the audience
because audiences speak with their
dollars critics you know they speak with
a score that may or may not impact the
box-office at the end of the day and for
the record most analytical types have
determined that it doesn't really impact
things particularly one way or the other
but looking at why aren't adding to this
like you would expect well to pull a
line that was originally said in terms
of wrestling and I know from Jim
sterling because he talks about it in
terms of video games but when the
business is hot you can do no wrong when
the business is cold you can do no right
now
gonna pick that apart if you've never
heard it but the short version of that
is when you're making money you assume
everything is great we're whatever we're
doing is validated because obviously
we're making money so people are fine
with it and that is when you tend to
make your mistakes that is when you do
your damage but because the effects of
the damage you're doing while you're
making money
don't become evident until a little
while later when you start losing money
by the time you start correcting you're
like oh we need to fix this and do
things right people have already cooled
on you now the business is cold because
you did all this damage when the
business was hot so now when you're
trying to bring it back up by actually
doing better stuff you've already lost a
chunk of your audience they bailed after
giving you that money you know back when
you were hot and you thought everything
was fine and I think Justice League is
suffering that suffering from that to a
certain extent because you know like I
said there were mixed to bad
receptions to Man of Steel Batman V
Superman and Suicide Squad and I know
some people like to tell you well
obviously audiences liked it much more
than critics except that at least
anecdotally in my experience audiences
didn't really like some people some
people did really like both but in terms
of the percentages I don't think it's as
far off as the defenders of those
earlier films like to claim that they
are I do think that by and large
audiences were giving DC the benefit of
the doubt with Man of Steel through
Batman V Superman through Suicide Squad
but then by then they were kind of going
oh I don't know anymore
and the question then becomes well why
didn't Wonder Woman build it back up and
the thing is the first thing to remember
is Wonder Woman though we did open
bigger than Justice League not by much
that opened I think at 103 which was
ahead of its expectations but the main
reason that Wonder Woman who was a big
success was that it had legs it did not
have a big drop Weekend over weekend and
that you can chalk up largely to
word-of-mouth people saying oh it's
really good and then people going so
that explains why Wonder Woman has been
such a success but why didn't that carry
over why didn't that help make Justice
League a big success well because
justice Lee
just tied up with a lot of baggage from
the movie that people didn't like so
much and that's Batman V Superman you've
got that Batman back you've got that
director back yes I know he was removed
just we can finish but his name's still
on it and you can still see his
fingerprints all over it
and it's an it's a direct continuation
of that story so Wonder Woman in many
ways is anomalous because it is the most
removed from the other films than the DC
EU so far it has the fewest connections
it's the most standalone so on the one
hand that means that Wonder Woman is not
as dragged down by the baggage of that
Cinematic Universe having not really
connected yet it also means that it
being successful doesn't buoy the rest
of that cinematic universe the way that
it might have otherwise and so that's
sort of my assessment on what happened
so the question is what's next well what
I'm hoping is that the folks at Warner
Brothers will realize sort of the
delayed negative box-office reaction to
what they've been doing that they kind
of already knew people weren't going for
and they have already made changes and
and and I said this in my review Justice
League very much feels like a middle
step course Craig it feels like the
pivot move and they're not they had they
didn't have the ability to completely
change it into what they now think they
want to alter this universe to be but it
is also a step away from what it was
that wasn't working so it's it's the
pivot move and then theoretically next
movies we start actually getting things
pointing towards where a warner brothers
and and the folks at DC have decided
where it's gonna go and I'm hoping that
they basically accept Justice League as
a loss leader that it is a movie that is
not going to do as well because of the
damage done by the earlier films but to
not take it under performing as meaning
oh this new direction doesn't work I
hope they will think you're okay well
this underperform but that's cuz we have
to build the good will back so that is
my hope that they don't look at this and
go ah the new direction isn't working
either and then they start scrambling
again like they did in the wake of
Batman V Superman I really hope that
isn't the case and I
hopefully they're paying attention to
fan reactions because again not only for
myself but for most of the people who
I've talked with who have seen it most
of them have been if not thrilled with
it not upset by it not disappointed
there's nowhere near so the anger that I
saw thrown at Batman V Superman so I'm
hoping that Warner Brothers has there
has their finger on that pulse so that
they are realizing that this can be a
first start to winning back some
goodwill and building things back up
again it's just if they expect sort of
immediate response and immediate turn on
that's where they're gonna make a dumb
mistake because I mean that's how they
got into this mess cuz you rationalize
thinking what we did this thing and
people are saying it wasn't good but
they paid all this money for it it must
be fine no it takes a little while for
the reaction to actually translate to
dollars both in the negative and in the
positive so hopefully they're gonna take
that into account and that's kind of why
I'm hoping they're gonna scrap the idea
of doing a the flash movie as flashpoint
because the obvious reason to do that is
to be able to do major changes to this
universe with an in continuity
explanation I don't I don't think that's
necessary anymore I think they've shown
with this movie that they can adjust the
universe as they are already making it
and the sort of hard changes that
flashpoint or that sort of reboot would
mean I don't think are actually
necessary though and the main thing that
I think they need to do is they need to
de-emphasize the the continuity honestly
they need to you know get good directors
onto these things have them at best be
doing continuity nods but not have films
where the primary thing is setting up
what comes next because regardless of
what you think of a story of Batman V
Superman a big part of its mandate in
terms of what it was supposed to
accomplish as a film was to directly set
up justice league and Wonder Woman and
all this other stuff to come after and
you know if you're looking at the Marvel
movies yes they usually set things up
but it would be in limited doses it
would be like here's this thread and
we'll pick that thread up in the next
movie but that
that stuff was also usually fairly
removable they didn't try to integrate
it directly into the story and how to
drive the plot the way setting up
justice league and other things tried to
do a Batman V Superman which is why that
story just doesn't come together it's
trying to do too many things at the same
time it was also one of the problems
with the amazing spider-man 2 I really
hope that they just refocus on what it
should have been in the first place the
individual characters the individual
franchises get them in the hands of good
directors good writers people with
vision and then leave them alone and
don't overly dictate what they need to
do to tie everything together and I say
that about DC and I don't say that about
Marvel because at this point Marvel has
very very clearly has a fairly
well-oiled machine that they just take
directors that they feel will work well
on the machine they plug them and they
let them go
there are mandates and controls and
limits in place within that machine but
it's obviously running fine at this
point again regardless of what you
personally think of the MCU that is a
machine that works even if you
personally don't like the end result the
machine at DC wasn't functioning
properly at all so they need to just
take the whole thing apart and focus on
the individual components ie the
individual characters the individual
franchises that was why Wonder Woman
worked because since it was a period
piece set before all the other stuff
that we'd already gotten it did not
require direct tie-ins to all this other
stuff the way other things have up to
this point so that is my hope my hope is
that Warner Brothers and DC can look at
these box office returns can look at
these numbers and go okay this is a
result of the decisions we made before
which we were already changing and don't
make the mistake of going this is a
result of the new direction we went the
new direction isn't working either
we got a scramble again that's the worst
thing they could do that's gonna lead to
chaos and a lot of crap or just movies
not happening and asthma I know I had a
video said why I want the DC EU to fail
the thing is I think it has or at least
the original vision of what the DC EU is
going to be has failed and I think the
box office alt results for Justice
League our aim
result of that and so while in that
video I may have shouted how I want this
to fail so hard they have to do a clean
slate reboot of everything I don't think
that's actually necessary anymore so in
a way I kind of get to have my cake you
needed to which is that they already
realized it didn't work they're moving
it in a new direction they're doing it
without having to hard reset everything
so that the things that did work gal
gadot as one of them being the main one
but now honestly some components of
Justice League as well can be retained
and we don't have to we don't have to
throw the baby out with the bathwater so
that's sort of my overall thoughts on
what I think the justice league box
office means in terms of how we got here
and what it could mean going forward
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that is on I Apple podcast it's not
iTunes anymore and stitcher radio I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast comm links for everything
is down below and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]